Bacteria lives everywhere, the sky, the earth,
the oceans, and IN YOUR BEARD! *pointing*
Sup guys, Trace here for DNews.
I am going to shampoo the crap out of my face
after this one.
Recently, the Daily Mail Online reported an
interview with a trichologist from the Birmingham
Trichology Center[1] and she said, facial
hair is "courser than other hair, so traps
dirt and germs more easily."
So we wanted to know, on behalf of my bearded
brethren, are beards gross and germy!?!
Is this a thing?!
Human skin is covered microbes, including
bacteria, archaea, fungi, viruses and mites[2].
Constantly.
Don't reach for the antibacterial whatever,
most of it is either good for you, or harmless.
In fact, a study in Nature looking at the
diversity of bacteria on our skin[3] found
different parts of the skin have different
species of bacteria.
For example, the bottom of the heel alone
has 80 different species of bacteria living
there.
Most of the skin is considered a harsh environment
for bacteria -- But in folds of skin, darker
wetter areas like underarms, or oily spots
like behind the ear -- bacteria thrive[4].
According to Skin Pharmacology & Physiology,
25% of our bacterial population live in the
hair follicles![5] Again, this is completely
normal, and CAN be beneficial.
Other studies have shown washing your face
won't clear all the bacteria.
In fact, in the 1960s, a U.S. Army microbiologist
researcher[6] looked into the ability of beard
hair to hold bacteria and transmit it to other
people.
Researchers sprayed beards with non-infectious
bacteria; allowed them to rest in the hair
for a while -- and then washed.
After the cleaning, there was STILL enough
bacteria to spread disease.
This experiment has been repeated a number
of times with similar results.
And mustaches aren't safe either.
According a specialist from Queen's University
in Canada, mustaches are hotbeds for bacteria
because of the moist air leaving the body
through the nose and mouth.
Thus, even MORE bacteria.
I KNEW mustaches were gross!
I KNEW IT.
After a study published in the journal Microbiology
and Immunity[7], repeated the experiment (yet
again) they claimed we should find a way to
decontaminate human hair.
So…
I'm sorry to say friends, beards probably
have bacteria in them.
BUT in case it hasn't become clear yet; it's
NOT JUST BEARDS.
Scientists from the University of Arizona
tested the hairbrushes of 30 different women,
and found 20 percent more bacteria living
on the brush than on the bathroom sink[8].
The brushes contained dead skin, oil and (obviously)
hair!
Okay, okay, I'll stop fear-mongering; remember,
the flora which live in and on our bodies
ISN'T going to harm us; it's symbiotic.
It feeds on our oils and dead skin cells.
the bacteria living in your beard is the same
that lives on your skin, and it's ALWAYS THERE.
Shaving won't rid you of this evil beard bacteria.
If, for some reason, you ARE worried; all
bacteria can be managed by regular hygiene:
shampoo or soap your hair to cut oil and thus
bacterial load.
Also, just a general non-gross rule, make
sure there's no FOOD caught in your beard!
Sure, humans are gross and icky and whatever,
but we've been this way for millions of years!
Why worry about it now?
If you're questioning your facial hair now,
you should watch my video about how we've
reached PEAK BEARD.
Beards are SO OVER.
They're NOT SEXY anymore.
That's why I straddle the divide with this
half-beard.
Check it out here *point down*